انا اتحدث الى هذا الفريق من الشبان
السوريين جاؤوا للتو من وسط الركام هم
يعملون منذ بدايه الازمه قاموا باخراج
اشخاص على قيد الحياه لهم تجارب سريعه
واسمحي لي ان استفسر منهم عن بعض الامور
تحياتي انت الاختيار ان نتحدث اليك اولا
يعطيكم الف عافيه على جهودكم
كم جثه على قيد كم شخص على قيد الحياه
اخرجتوه وكم جثه لمتوفي تقريبا الله
يعافيك نشكر على قناه الحدث العربيه
العربيه القناه الحدث العربيه نشكره على
وصول المناطق نحن شبان من قريه اسمها
شحروره من باير بوجك وبعد هذه الزلزال
سبحان الله هذا طوعتم للمساعده المساعده
هذه الاشخاص تحت الركام الحمد لله تم بعون
الله سبحانه وتعالى اخراج ما بين 10 او 15
شخص عقيد الح قيد الحياه وما يقارب شي 20
شخص متوفين متى اخر حاله اخرجتوها كانت
على قيد الحياه قبل يومين يعني في خمس
ايام بعد الزلزال اخرجنا طفلين الحمد لله
حدث معنا موقفين هم استغربت منهم مواقف
غريبه بدي اسالك عن المواقف الغريبه اول
منهم عائله تركيه اخرجهم طبعا نحن
كما سمعنا الصوت نخرج بعون الله نخرج
السمعنا الصوت ان كان تركي او
ما في تمييز افهمك افهم سبحان الله عائله
تركيا اخرجناهم بعون الله تمينا شي ثلاث
ساعات حتى نقدر نوصل لعندهم بعد ما وصلنا
الاخت طلعت سليم ما فيها شيء
والرجل على اجره تحت الاركان بين الباطون
تمينا اربع او ثلاث ساعات كمان بس التحرير
رجله سبحان الله اخر شيء فقد الامل وقال
اقطع اجري يا الله اي والله قال اقطع اجري
واخرجني قلت له لا يا اخي ان شاء الله انا
بدي احاول لحتى احرر سبحان الله الحمد لله
الله عز وجل
وتخلى عن رجله حتى بلحظه اي والله عن رجله
حتى يخرج بدنه الحمد لله الله عز وجل
وحررنا الموقف الاخر لانه مع الناس شي وقت
كثير اسف بس يعني موقف الاخر سبحان الله
اخرجنا الطفل
في عمر 11 سنه
قبل ما نوصل لعندو سالناه مين معك قال
خالتي وابن خالتي قلنا له مين متوفي قال
بس لاخرج ان شاء الله انا استغربت من زكاه
الطفل قال بس ان شاء الله اخرج نتكلم بعد
ما خرج قال خالتي عايشه وابنها متوفي
سبحان الله جوا قال هذا الحكي مشان ما
يسمع خالتو خالتو ما بتعرفي عشان ما
يجرحها يعني عشان عشان ما يجرحها تحت
الركام طيب انا بدي اسالك عشان الضيق
الوقت واسف انتم جئتم من هناك للتو وغدا
صباحا راح تتوجهوا للعمل مره اخرى ان شاء
الله سؤال مهم من خبرتكم واللي بتشتغلوه
هل يتزال هنالك اعداد كبيره من الجثث تحت
الركام برايك والله اداه كثيره اعداد
قليله للخروج من تعطيكم اعداد كثيره جدا
جدا لا تزال لا تزال الاعداد كثيره تحت
الركام يعني اعداد قليله اللي خرجوا قياسا
باللي بقوا طب السؤال كمان اخيرا باعتقادك
هذا الدمار
الموجود في انطاكيا وفي هاتاي من خبرتكم
وانتم بتشوفوا المواقع كم يحتاج من الوقت
برايك حتى يزال كل الركام وتخرج كل الجثث
من تحته يعني تقريبا هلا كل جزء اساسي
يخرج من تحته كم هذا صعب لانه في مناطق ما
يخرج منه قصدي كم يحتاج اسبوع شهر كم عده
اشهر شهرين او ما فوق شهرين او شهر وما
فوق يعني